welcome to another stories from the
stores now today we're joined by curator
Alex Rose and she's told me that this
instrument can measure ozone Alex how
does it work
ozone is a gas that's produced up in the
stratosphere so that's a layer of the
Earth's atmosphere that's between 10 and
50 kilometers up an ozone absorbs UV
light from the Sun okay like a layer of
sun cream basically like a layer of sun
cream and that's the principle basically
that this instrument uses to measure
ozone it was made in 1924 by a
university professor called Gordon
Dobson in his shed and he realized that
no one had taken regular measurements of
ozone basically and he wanted to create
a continuous data set so he constructed
this instrument to do that it would have
been mounted so that you could adjust
the height there's a scale on the side
where you can see what angle is pointing
out so that you could angle it at the
Sun or whatever angle you wanted is that
why it's got a bubbling stuff yeah
exactly so that he could calculate the
height it has a filter at this end that
separated out the wavelengths of light
that he was interested in recording
there's a prism here that kind of splits
out the lights and then the readings
would have been taken on a photographic
plate that SATs
just down there okay so he's taking all
of these readings right did he find that
hole in the ozone layer he didn't
because in 1924 it didn't exist what he
did discover was that the levels of
ozone weren't constant but they
fluctuated a lot so they varied daily
they varied annually seasonally so did
they use this object to discover the
hole in the ozone layer it was a modern
version of this instrument stationed at
Antarctica actually that a number of
British scientists were looking at
measurements from and they realized that
levels of ozone were much lower than
they were expecting and were declining
so after the initial findings in the mid
1980s there was a big international
research project that confirmed and the
findings that there was a hole in the
ozone layer and the world came together
to ban the use of CFC
in manufacturing industry which was the
cause of the whole and that's all thanks
to Dobson exactly so scientists still
use his name every time they take
measurements because and the modern
versions of this instrument are called
Dobson meters by scientists and the unit
of measurement for atmospheric ozone in
fact bears his name it's called the
Dobson
you
[Music]